i am so excited to see how katherine's
makeup um turned out uh let's see
katherine before and all her all or
nothing glory looks all right and let's
um see catherine now come on out
[Applause]
oh my god
i'm sorry but i can't even help it
you're so hot
like oh my god you really like wow that
is the power of beauty but the most
important thing is how do you feel
i feel great this look is fantastic the
makeup the the uh face oil is
so lightweight it feels like nothing
the lip balm is very hydrating the
mascara i actually can't wait to try the
mascara myself that's my
chair
okay i mean
speaking to the products tell us about
what you did well also speaking to the
fact that it's green but it also
looks beautiful like
catherine your skin is glowing you look
amazing so we just paired back her look
we went with something casual she could
wear all the time
do it herself i just and then we sent
her to the salon we put some highlights
in her and
warmed it up a bit and the highlights
are really good because they're not too
juxtaposing when i see a highlight that
isn't the right tint or tone i get so
mad oh i know me too i'm like why did
you do that to that person you just
turned them into tiger zebra
and i like i like that they don't start
at the root they kind of just
fade out and they get lighter towards
the bottom
[Applause]
do you
feel empowered because
baby man you look so beautiful i have to
say you know i i'm always in scrubs
or running
or then i'm in an evening gown so this
you know i feel like a businesswoman
like i'm
you know ready to go like i'm ready to
take on the world well your husband and
and brother are here is that true
[Applause]
um
may i ask your husband and brother how
you guys feel
about this look and what you think of
your extraordinary wife and sister
drew i agree with you she looks hot she
looks really bad
[Applause]
she always looks beautiful but yeah
she's fantastic and i'm so proud of her
and uh she went through a lot these past
couple of years and uh she deserves this
she does she does
all right and she looks like she looks
like a totally different person to me
i'm i only i usually only see her at
work
so i usually only see her in that uh
non-makeup you know look
and uh yeah it looks amazing well i'm so
glad you gentlemen approve that's so
wonderful
and
catherine we're gonna give a bundle of
the makeup green edition to you
um and boy did everybody come on a good
day because we are giving everyone in
the audience um you are going home with
a maybelline green edition makeup and
100 gift card to walmart
gift certificate to walmart so chocolate
makeup gift cards
[Applause]
to learn what green edition means please
visit maybelline.com backslash green
edition they are leading the charge may
we all follow this gives me so much hope
and i'm so grateful to work with
maybelline
[Applause]
[Music]